[Music]
on this monday night mounting concerns
about monkey pox in canada the criticism
suggesting this vaccine campaign needs a
shot in the arm the fact that it's not
widely available now seems to be getting
overlooked
intensifying infernos the west coast
wildfires threatening hundreds of homes
close call caught on camera
the brave bystanders rescuing a man from
a raging bull and the art of recovery
the first time in my life i don't want
to die anymore the young man painting
with purpose and helping others heal
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news a u.s drone
strike in afghanistan has killed ayman
al-zawahiri the leader of al-qaeda and
one of the world's most wanted
terrorists
justice has been delivered and this
terrorist leader is no more
u.s president joe biden making an
address from the white house tonight but
providing few details about the
operation that killed the egyptian
surgeon who became a mastermind of jihad
against the west al-zawari oversaw the
september 11th attacks and had been in
hiding ever since
following the 2011 killing of osama bin
laden by u.s special forces al-zawari
took over as al-qaeda's leader and
remained a top target of western
anti-terror operations since
biden confirmed there were no civilian
deaths in the operation and none of
al-zawari's family was killed
back here in canada monkey pox cases are
rising and so too are concerns health
officials aren't moving fast enough to
make sure everyone who wants the vaccine
can get it for now the immunization is
targeted at the gay community as shawn
o'shea reports some people are wondering
if that's why the vaccine rollout isn't
going any faster
with canadian monkey pucks cases above
800 the global health emergency has now
hit at least one unidentified toronto
homeless shelter public health officials
in canada's largest city have
transferred a person who tested positive
for the virus into an isolation and
recovery site a location originally
designed for people diagnosed with covet
19 while those deemed at high risk line
up for vaccinations everyone's trying to
protect their health it should just be
widely available there were long lineups
at the toronto monkey box vaccination
clinic and some questions covered 19
affected everybody so it was available
like almost immediately for everybody
but this seems to be a really slow roll
up for some reason at this pop-up
vaccination clinic at vancouver pride on
sunday there was strong interest in
getting as much protection as possible
people are incredibly thankful to be
receiving their vaccines
folks that are really really scared
about the infection really really scared
about the virus going around the vaccine
is targeted for now at the gay community
said with no stigma no discrimination
and no moralization the highest risk
community right now is in the men who
have sex with men community especially
those who are having multiple partners
or multiple contacts but critics of how
governments are sourcing and
distributing the vaccine wonder if the
effort would be faster if those at
greatest risk weren't gay the fact that
it's not widely available now seems to
be getting overlooked and that does seem
to be a little bit unfair but there's a
reason says infectious diseases expert
dr isaac bogash there's a global
shortage of this vaccine he says
targeting the highest risk communities
makes sense appropriately the vaccines
and the public health programs are very
tailored to that particular community
that might change with time you know if
this starts if we start to see cases in
other cohorts in other areas so the
focus now gets many vaccines into the
arms of those in the community who want
it right now neetu
shawn o'shea in toronto thanks sean
a growing wildfire in bc's okanagan
region has prompted more evacuation
orders for a mountain resort village the
caramel's creek wildfire was only
sparked on friday but is moving fast
about 300 properties including some
homes on the province's largest first
nation reserve are affected this morning
officials estimated the fire covered
about 400 hectares but that has since
changed to more than 2 thousand most of
the fire is located in steep and
inaccessible terrain making it difficult
to fight to help staff at apex mountain
ski resort have fired up their snow
making machines which can spray water
about 45 meters away
we did have cruise and structure
protection working overnight last night
throughout the night to respond to this
fire we do anticipate that it did grow
over the past 24 hours or so and is
continuing to do so
there is a heat warning in effect for
the okanagan as well as a thunderstorm
in the forecast but temperatures are
expected to be cooler over the next few
days which is expected to help
firefighters
two bodies have been found in a burned
out car in northern california on the
trail of the largest wildfire in the
state this year the fast-moving mckinney
fire first broke out friday and has
already forced more than 2 thousand
people to leave while destroying homes
and critical infrastructure more than 22
thousand hectares have already burned
and the fire is completely uncontained
officials say heavy smoke has hampered
efforts to fight the fire from the air
california governor gavin newsom
declared a state of emergency for the
county which will help unlock funding
and resources
in kentucky at least 35 people are dead
after days of flooding caused by heavy
rain
the region is already bracing for more
rainfall forecast overnight into tuesday
as residents grapple with washed away
homes overflowed rivers and mudslides
washington has already declared a
federal disaster to bring more aid and
relief the state governor warns many
people are still unaccounted for and the
death toll will rise as search efforts
expand
there are hundreds of unaccounted for
people minimum and we just we just don't
have a firm grasp on that i wish we did
there are a lot of reasons why it's
nearly impossible but i want to make
sure that we're not we're not given
either false hope
or faulty information
more than ten thousand residents are
also reportedly still without power from
the disaster and later this week the
region will also be hit by excessive
heat of up to 37 degrees
in ukraine russian forces focused more
overnight shelling on the port city of
mikolayev hitting a hospital trauma
center firefighters rushed to the scene
to try and contain the flames and limit
the damage a demining crew was also
brought in to the site to make it safe
for the emergency response at this point
there's no word on the number of
casualties a number of residential and
office buildings were also hit in the
same barrage the strategically important
city borders the mostly russian occupied
hairson region
for the first time since russia launched
its invasion a ship carrying ukrainian
grain left the port of odessa under a
u.n broker deal the rizzoni and the
ships to follow it should have safe
passage through the black sea and onto
global markets as redmond shannon
reports the resumption of shipments of
ukrainian grain should help ease the
global food crisis exacerbated by the
invasion
under high security preparations for a
voyage delayed by more than five months
the rizzoni is the first grain ship to
leave odessa since russia's february
invasion loaded with 26 000 tons of corn
it's bound for lebanon via turkey i am
very happy and my crew also
so much
happy to leave
this support the rizzoni is one of 17
grain vessels that had been stuck here
since war broke out the deal brokered by
the u.n with the help of turkey allows
them to leave ukraine will guide the
ships through the mined waters while
russia has agreed not to target the
black sea port during the shipments
crew members like abdullah say it's a
relief after a scary period in odessa
last month russian missiles hit the port
just a day after the deal was agreed
the merchant vessel razzoni
is loaded with two commodities in short
supply corn and hope hope that the grain
trade from ukraine can soon ramp up
again to temper rising food prices
particularly in africa and the middle
east russia and ukraine are two of the
biggest exporters of wheat and sunflower
seeds those involved in the trade say
getting stranded ships out is one thing
getting fresh vessels into odessa will
be another the main obstacle
is
the cost of insurance for
shipowners
still we don't have firm conditions
how much do
they have to pay that cost will depend
on the success of the rizzone's voyage
and could yet deter some grain buyers i
think the very first vessels will be old
one which is cheapest one and small one
part of turkey's role is to ensure that
those ships won't smuggle arms into
ukraine
despite the deep mistrust between moscow
and keeve both welcomed the rizzone's
departure a very rare moment where the
two sides agree redmond shannon global
news london
the kremlin says a major reduction in
the flow of energy to europe is out of
its hands according to russian energy
giant gazprom a key turbine for the
nordstream one pipeline has still not
arrived on site after undergoing service
in canada the company says a second
turbine is showing defects last week
russia cut the supply of natural gas
through the pipeline to 20 percent of
capacity a move the european union has
called energy blackmail
new video shows the moment on sunday
when part of a huge and badly damaged
silo collapsed near the beirut
waterfront
[Music]
back in august 2020 the silo was the
site of one of the largest non-nuclear
explosions ever recorded that killed 215
people wounding more than 6 000 others
and damaging thousands of buildings that
blast was caused by improperly stored
ammonium nitrate which is used as
fertilizer and an explosive officials
had issued a warning the wrecked
structure could collapse further and say
a fire had been smoldering inside for
weeks
a rampaging bull at an alberta rodeo
coming up the panic moments when the
animal went after a man
plus the eroding confidence in the rcmp
there were some frightening moments at a
running of the bulls event in alberta
over the weekend and a warning while
this video is tough to watch everyone is
said to be ok
a bull charged at a man flipping him
over before coming at him again that's
when alberta mla and ucp leadership
candidate leela ahir jumped the fence
trying to stop the bull from trampling
the man others joined in to help ahir
whose campaign manager tweeted this
video says the man was not injured and
the bull is doing fine as well
canada's national police force is under
strain and under the microscope the
inquiry into the rcmp response to the
2020 nova scotia mass shooting is still
ongoing while the force's reputation has
never recovered from a series of
investigations and lawsuits over sexual
harassment as ross lord reports some
senior police managers are now admitting
drastic measures could soon be required
just for the force to maintain services
it took more than two years but the rcmp
has finally admitted it came up short
during the port-a-pick massacre that
left 22 people murdered
i'm truly sorry that we failed you
evidence of the mass casualty
commission's public inquiry shows a
range of rcmp's shortcomings from
containing the gunman to disjointed
communication among members with the
general public and to victims families
they need to start looking at
trusting their members judgment i mean
that's the job they were hired for and
if you're not
capable of doing that then maybe they
shouldn't be doing that job the rcmp's
failures have led to some communities
considering creating their own police
forces
rather than continue contracting out to
the maudies and according to some who
study policing in canada evidence
alleging political interference in the
port-a-peck investigation could worsen
an already shaky relationship if the
police are just sort of in cahoots with
the government and uh the appearance is
to the public that they are operating
politically this is entirely problematic
for police legitimacy and further
contributes to the erosion of police
legitimacy he says if public confidence
is gone so is effective policing when
you have an erosion of trust a lack of
trust
the the public are obviously less likely
to cooperate with the police i mean why
would they rebuilding trust is impaired
by chronic staff shortages following the
massacre the rcmp was forced to staff
some nova scotia detachments with
members who'd normally work in traffic
services leaving that division
shorthanded
it's a measure senior maudi's fear they
might soon need to repeat but the
downstream factor that is obvious road
safety will
potentially suffer in late august more
rcmp higher-ups are scheduled to testify
at the public inquiry among the
witnesses commissioner brenda lucky as
current controversies and the rcmp's
role in future policing come under more
scrutiny
ross lord global news
ahead the squabble between texas and
washington that's left countless
migrants marooned in the u.s capital
in the u.s the texas governor is locking
horns with the mayor of washington d.c
as migrants from mexico are being sent
by the busload to the nation's capital
muriel bowser is calling the transport
cruel political gamesmanship and she's
now asking the federal government for
help as her city's resources are getting
overwhelmed with migrants who have
nowhere to live jennifer johnson reports
busloads of migrants from texas arrive
in the nation's capital every week over
4 thousand seeking asylum in the past
few months the numbers are so
overwhelming that washington's mayor has
asked the federal government to deploy
the national guard indefinitely i've
asked for the deployment of the guard as
long as we need the guard to deal with
the humanitarian crisis
that we expect to escalate the city is
caught in the middle of a feud between
texas governor greg abbott and the biden
administration abbott vowed to bust
undocumented migrants to d.c if
president joe biden didn't stop them
from crossing into his state we are
sending them to the united states
capital where the body administration
will be able to more immediately address
the needs of the people that they are
allowing to come across our border the
migrants say when they arrived in texas
they were given the option to travel to
washington under false promises never
imagining they'd be left without food or
shelter
they told us with lies they told us to
come to d.c they have help here they
have work here they offer you
they offer you jobs
tell you that they're going to help you
but then they just drop you off here
like an animal many of the migrants are
now sleeping outdoors in the summer heat
on the grounds near the u.s capitol
local charities are trying to help but
they can't keep up it's really difficult
the funds have run out so we can't send
people right away to their final
destination we have to remember the
majority of people do not want to stay
charities are begging the d.c government
for money to provide basic necessities
or send the migrants to other cities
where they have family or friends we
have never received any money from the
d.c government or any government all our
money has been grassroots raised the
federal emergency management agency has
given the city over 2 million dollars in
aid but dc's mayor is asking the white
house for millions more we know that the
federal government does this because we
see this type of response
with afghan refugees
and now we see it with people who are
coming to united states from ukraine
in the meantime migrants like anna
karina are stranded their dreams of a
better life in america lay shattered at
the foot of the nation's capital
jennifer johnson global news washington
the first january 6 defendant to go to
trial has been sentenced to more than
seven years in prison prosecutors say
guy refit led the mob charging the
police line outside the west steps of
the u.s capitol while carrying a gun and
zip ties at the time refit was a member
of the texas three percenters a
far-right militia but now says he no
longer wants to have any association
with the group
inspiration against addiction next the
artist drawing hope at the epicenter of
bc's drug crisis
today black communities across canada
are reflecting on their heritage and
continuing calls for change on this
emancipation day
[Music]
celebrations of black history mixed with
demands for more systemic action against
racism in events like these in halifax
as black canadians marked 188 years
since britain abolished slavery across
the colonies that saw more than eight
000 people of african descent freed in
1834
but not before millions were enslaved
throughout the british empire's history
as an epicenter of the toxic drug crisis
homelessness and crime vancouver's
downtown east side has a reputation as
one of the toughest and most challenged
neighborhoods in the entire country but
one vancouver artist says the community
has been both his inspiration and
salvation and he credits it for helping
him overcome addiction and depression
kristin robinson has the story
being able to set up for a public art
show every saturday has been a long
journey for chris blake cook i never
thought i would survive myself long
enough to see any of my dreams come true
how much is that one i have a list
few buyers are aware the young artist
emerged from darkness
while battling depression in alberta at
the start of covid cook turned to hard
drugs and alcohol he says he tried
suicide three times before a friend
encouraged him to move to vancouver and
i was just trying to like escape the
chaos in my head by november 2020 cook
was painting a new path living at union
gospel mission he tried to stay sober
but relapsed before entering recovery
after a sixth suicide attempt last
august he started to draw gifting his
art to the guys in the program i would
hear
hey you know that drawing you gave me i
look at that every day and it gets me
through the day so i was like oh my
heart is doing something i didn't see
right
so this is like one of the first ones
trapped inside my mind cook's healing
documented through his art i still
showcase the pain but now you can see
the light and the pain right
when he graduated cook started posting
his work it got noticed he sold 15
pieces at his first show with the
downtown east side artists collective
i walked home with this big smile i was
like
it's
the first time in my life i don't want
to die anymore
it felt really good
cook realized he had a purpose
this piece loved was designed as a
tattoo to cover up scars a hard one for
him to sell
until he shared the story with the right
person she said
wow now i really have to buy it and i
said oh oh why's that and she said well
i have a tattoo on my wrist to cover up
my suicide attempt she shared it online
and helped other people and felt good
while the downtown east side can be
cruel cook says it saved his life i
learned that i had to go through all
that pain so i can help other people
and the people here that are using they
just haven't been able to process their
pain and trauma
but they don't deserve to die everyone
needs to know their love he says and be
treated with kindness and compassion
having a safe place to live and and some
friends that actually cared about me
yeah bro it saved me and i was able to
be here today kristin robinson global
news
and that's global national for this
monday tonight's your canada is the
stratford festival theater in stratford
ontario thanks for watching have a great
night
[Music]
you